Ukrainian authorities report
a series of Russian rocket attacks
hit a residential building
in the city of Zaporizhzhia overnight.
Emergency response
teams rescued nine people,
including a pregnant woman.
The attack killed
at least two people and rescue
efforts are ongoing.
Officials are raising concerns
about the safety of the nearby
nuclear power plant.
The head of the International
Atomic Energy Agency says the plant faces
persistent security risks due to the war.
This Saturday will mark one year since
Russian forces
seized control of the nuclear site.
And as CNN's Clare
Sebastian reports, experts are worried
Russia's tight grip on the facility
could lead to disaster
A year into its occupation
of the Parisian
nuclear power plant,
Russia is making changes.
Satellite images
showing the dry storage area
where spent nuclear fuel is kept
after being cooled
first in August last year.
Then at the end of February,
what looks like a wall of structure
has appeared.
Russia's atomic energy company
Rosatom tells state media
it's building a shield to protect
against Ukrainian artillery strikes.
A local Russian backed
official posted this in December,
calling it a protective dome.
It's only
doing what was
supposed to impact nuclear safety.
The head of Ukraine's
atomic energy company
and Erika
Adams
says it's all part
of a deteriorating situation.
It's a pariah
that he is powerless to stop.
What is the biggest risk right now
when it comes to safety in the plant?
Well, yeah,
because those things that we don't know
what is the fence of the moment
you can expect.
And
so they continue
shelling on the ground for example,
another atom says Russia,
which forcibly took over the plant
last March,
damaging several buildings
in the process,
continues to use it
as a de facto military base.
This video surfaced
last summer of military
trucks in one of the turbine buildings
next to a reactor last month.
An atom accused Russia
of bringing hundreds of newly
mobilized troops to the site
before deploying them to the east.
Rosatom is own press
service for the power plant,
denied there's any heavy
military equipment on site,
but noted that Russia's
National Guard troops,
Putin's domestic security force,
are guarding the plant.
I'm very worried about the supplies.
I'm very worried.
And that Atom says
the plant
has been cut off
from the electricity grid
five times in total,
leaving diesel generators
the last line of
defense before a catastrophe.
Fighting has
also come to close
The IAEA reports shelling into building
housing fresh nuclear fuel in September
and a reactor building in November.
And that atom now estimates
four and a half thousand
Ukrainian staff
are left
at the plant out of 11,000
before the war.
That reduction of the number of people
is going to have
a significant impact
on their ability
to maintain and function sort of systems,
whether or not
that security systems, safety
systems, radiation
monitoring, nuclear expert
Nick Tomkinson says he is working
with the Ukrainian government
to try to deploy radiation
mapping systems
and to Parisa and other nuclear sites.
One of the concerns could be that
things could go missing
and bombs are easier, particularly
some of the fuel.
I'm not worried about my.
What I'd be worried about
was is an active decision
to do something.
Ukraine's nuclear
power company,
though, is worried about a slow
motion mistake
for maintenance
leading to the degradation
of the equipment on the site.
Including the reactors themselves.
Currently,
all in various states have shut down.
It is bore to the stage, though.
Nobody wants to
if we will be able to operate it.
This is just the start.
The Russian
side says
strict radiation safety
standards are being observed.
Hardly a consolation
when 20% of Ukraine's electricity supply
remains hostage to this war.
Whereas me, there is no let up.
The IAEA,
the UN's nuclear
watchdog, reports
last weekend that the backup power line
connecting the plant to the Ukrainian
electricity grid was severed again.
It was then restored.
The staff there also said
they had around 20 detonations
in the vicinity of the plant.
This as the IAEA is expressing concern
that a planned rotation
of staff to that
plant is more than three weeks late.
And I want to point out as well
that Rosatom, Russia's
nuclear energy
monopoly, continues
to avoid most Western sanctions,
even as
the rest of Russia's energy
industry has been heavily
sanctioned Rosemary.
Many thanks to Clare
Sebastian for that report.